hi guys I'm Gregory I'm actually
actually in Gregory are here today
because we ROCK cars three trailer by
the way how Tuesday Morgan and Ashley is
the channel I did an interview on her
channel coming up soon
co-host Morgan is off to the side
because she hasn't seen any of the cars
movies that's right we're doing car
three today they don't label it there
she is
he's given her we recently launched the
page around we normally do patron of the
day sheriff but no one is currently shut
up but joe visit our patreon and become
a part of the community let's watch the
trailer
you are Bucks become the biggest brand
team racing movie feels in commercial
products gosh you think you're famous
now looking rich beyond belief mr.
Sherman what is this about your legacy
every time you lose you damaged yourself
so intense I'm sorry the racing days are
coming to an end
Wow oh he's dead
whoever is driving that car can only
hope that this race today wasn't it
laughs I decide when I'm done
how you feeling I can't go out on the
track and do the same old thing it won't
work it's beauty is is change man you
know what I did what I don't know I know
everything I like a challenge
I call you my senior project oh the
beach ate me Josh's door set a new
record today when he pulled off the
fastest lap record how you see either
way today
[Music]
this is my last chance boos laughs
Bibles I never get beer
don't fear failure be afraid of not
having the chance you haven't I used to
watch you on TV
I fear ridiculous
[Music]
you'll never be as fastest story but you
can be smarter than you know Wow
[Music]
I don't know you might not it might be
like one of those stories were like
they're teaching you like even if you
come in second it's the journey NASA you
know it's what's the thing
oh yeah yes about the lessons you learn
along the journey and never like when
rocky went the distance in the first
rocky yeah like I'm lost but what matter
was he he did his best anyway yeah so
maybe he won't win maybe he will come in
- yeah or like bring it on when the
white girls lost the black girls black
girls something and I can't black are
way better way I mean every community at
the other trailers for this I just need
a tree like this all well I find that
these trailers are this one one of the
least heavy ones but I remember the
first teaser trailer was like super
serious this one seems pretty intense
yeah like there's not really that many
jokes
yeah Larry right literally Cable Guy
mater
yeah you only like actual jokin and the
yellow latina car get into this stance
but a lot of it seems like it's they're
going for the inspirational tale it's
like the underdog story yeah bringing it
back to the first ones and then the
second one was like a weird spy movie
that really had a lot of see the second
one and I really liked the first one but
I yeah I'm going to see the single one I
think that's okay though right it's just
get fun wasn't isn't the first one kind
of a similar story like this I don't
remember the first one that well I
remember he has to like find his way
Redemption I think he was like this
Aryan car thought he's like the best
wasn't like he goes to this small town
and they can I teach on like the meaning
of like actual love right any knows what
it was yeah yeah yeah cycle like there's
always like this like learning what I do
they go through exactly this is another
lesson for him sat/rad nice i fear
getting there one day you know
especially with the YouTube ad pocalypse
happening getting land you know where
you have to like make one final one
final race to the finish and if you
don't win it over well what if it over
something like out
is to the tenth store I mean I'm hope it
looks like the bringing back characters
from the first one they're introducing
new cars yes we still didn't get a good
look and I think the car's name is storm
the member that I have you and Jenna be
a win yeah [ __ ] Sacha Baron Cohen
well I wouldn't know but that suit Sacha
Baron Cohen was the bad guy
Talladega Nights got it yes yeah yes I
guess I guess we're saying I understand
the references that are being made I
will look I know this is your kind of
movie horror movies and kids them yeah
you write down I think it'd be really
cool if McQueen died yeah I think that
would be a such a risky maneuver to do
do these cars movies are primarily melee
that would happen in the child movie
like that the main character Mufasa died
yeah that's a little different though
because this is I mean if I were at a
different time where they probably
wouldn't do that
not only that didn't like the cars like
this Ben is done well I mean I guess
whole bunch of other talking cars
well Ashley I have hopes that they'll
kill them off I think it would be great
I think it'd be very uh very edgy a bold
move on there and make the story more
meaningful what if he wings but dies
along the way like you runs out of
gasoline or something but you know he's
no ever my car does it sound like a word
an answer no no no I have a good taste
in movies and I'm creative I know what
I'm talking about hey subscribe to the
real rejects it'll it quick that cell by
notification bill you got to do two
things in order to get notified the
[ __ ] but you got to do it hey Ashley ed
nerd is that Ashley editor on Instagram
she's also how to's with Morgan and
Ashley on you here I have a video coming
up there soon and also how to blonde
make a ride on Instagram that's right
that's probably one yeah
she was leaning right now she wishes she
wishes that would be so lucky
don't laugh we could have a chemistry
developing that every day a lot more